what are the five things you're most
excited about around bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in 2022 what are the
five things you're like bam this i'm
super excited to see this stuff happen
well bitcoin crypto funks uh board apes
are buying planets in the metaverse
um
and regulatory clarity i think i think
i'm excited about that kind of stuff all
right let's go in reverse
look look look look i'm a bitcoin money
maximalist
what does that mean
it just means that i think bitcoin is is
good money
it's um it's like a it's an insurance
wealth policy
uh and i'm totally in 100 in but i don't
think bitcoin
solves everything so i am looking around
at at different projects i've always
been interested in tinkering so you know
my bitcoin maximalist friends those
toxic guys you know they just think i've
gone brain dead full galaxy brain when i
talk about this other stuff but i'm
interested in it so you know i'm a
holder of of crypto punks and crypto
funks and and board apes and you know i
i think that there's something there i
think there's a cultural
a cultural shift there's a group of
people that don't care about the
programmatic monetary policy of bitcoin
they don't care about good money you
know they're they're in it for a
lifestyle and and they identify with
with these cultural movements and they
like they like video games and stuff so
look i i'm i'm older
and now
uh but i'm still uh interested in uh in
this space and and uh you know when i
say i'm older now i think i'm an older
bitcoiner you know i'm i'm a guy who has
assets and house a house with chairs a
lot of bitcoiners talk about like sell
your chairs for bitcoin for bitcoin
excuse me like i don't want to do that i
want to have a car and a house and i
want to go on vacations and i also want
to have bitcoin so when you think about
bitcoin as one of the five things that's
kind of a self-explanatory regulatory
clarity i think is another one that's
self-explanatory but you mentioned three
things there in the middle you said
crypto punks crypto funks and uh would
you say board apes i think right
explain more about those three things
why are those three of the five things
that you're excited about in 2022
yeah so crypto punks are kind of like og
ethereum based uh
jpegs or pngs and they kind of rug
pulled the uh the holders of those so i
i'm an owner of of crypto punks they're
worth a lot i think the floor is like 70
ethereum or something like that so what
is that 230 000 bucks or something uh
along along that way um they sold the ip
to a third party and i found it to be
really weird so they they almost like uh
took the value away from the people who
owned this asset and it caused a lot of
people to think
one of the the groups that i think did
something interesting was a group called
[ __ ] uh that invented or or produced
something called crypto funks they took
crypto punks and they flipped them
the other way so they're just facing the
other way they're exactly identical to
uh to crypto punks but not identical in
any form or fashion because they're
flipped the other way and um they're
kind of challenging
uh a lot of uh of dmca and claims around
copyright and what are your rights to
these uh these images and i've enjoyed
the exploration of that pomp and then
finally board apes you know they
they
lay claim to giving you the ip and the
right to actually go out and
commercialize your ape so you could you
could launch a clothing line with that
image and sell it as long as you hold it
you apparently have some rights and
privileges associated with that i think
that's really interesting
again this is uh
anyone can right click these images and
then anybody can sue anything anybody
for anything obviously so um that
remains to be seen how defensible these
positions are in court
but uh it's really interesting to me to
dive down this uh copyright
uh licensing trademark kind of situation
as a holder of some of these jpegs